-The Taliban have regained
control in Afghanistan,
amid a chaotic U.S. evacuation,
bringing a tragic end
to a 20-year bipartisan
foreign-policy disaster
that American officials
of both parties
bear responsibility for
and which they have
repeatedly lied about.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
The crushing reality of the
so-called global war on terror
is that some of the
highest-ranking officials
involved in it now admit
that it was a colossal failure,
and that's a reality
we should all grapple with.
Presidents, politicians, and
foreign-policy elites
of both parties
deserve blame for this calamity.
In his new book,
"Reign of Terror,"
author Spencer Ackerman writes,
"In 2020, I asked
Stanley McChrystal,
the former Joint Special
Operations Command
and Afghanistan War Commander,
if the War on Terror
had been worth it.
'It would be impossible to argue
that it was,' he answered.
'The outcome just hasn't been
positive enough to argue that.'"
That's not an anti-war activist
saying that.
That's a former commander
of the war in Afghanistan
saying the 20-year War on Terror
was a failure.
It's like if Kevin Feige said,
"Honestly, I have no idea
what's going on in the
Marvel cinematic universe.
None of it makes sense to me.
I mean, they
all have superpowers,
but every fight
comes down to karate?
What the hell, right?"
Of course, in reality,
the only thing
Feige has to apologize for
is not putting Vince Vaughn
in Loki.
You missed a huge opportunity
to create some buzz
and reunite the greatest comic
duo since Laurel and Hardy.
"Buddy, buddy, buddy.
And I say that because
there are three of you."
I'm sorry to reference 2005's
"Wedding Crashers."
That movie is so old,
it came out
four years after the start
of the war in Afghanistan.
A comment like that
from McChrystal,
the idea that the so-called
War on Terror
has been a 20-year failure
should provoke
some serious introspection
and soul-searching
on the part of
Washington elites.
And yet somehow
I can't exactly imagine
the people responsible
for this calamity
looking inward and holding
themselves accountable for it.
George W. Bush is too busy
in his art studio,
trying to, I don't know,
get a dog's eyebrow right.
So strange that
sandwiched between
James Patterson's co-author
and New England's
newest party promoter,
we have a former President
who's just okay at painting.
Also, were the dogs
supposed to look like him?
I'm not crazy, right?
Doesn't it kind of look like
the dogs have Bush's face?
And that expression of his
that says,
"I don't know the answer
to your question"?
[ Laughter ]
And, yet, as tragedy unfolds
in Afghanistan,
the political world is,
of course,
engaged in finger-pointing
for what has been a generational
bipartisan failure
that presidents and politicians
of both parties
bear responsibility for.
For example, over the weekend
former Trump Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo tried to claim
this would not have happened
under the previous
administration,
but got called out
by Fox host Chris Wallace.
-It looks like
the Biden administration
has just failed in its execution
of its own plan.
The plan should have been
much like we had,
was that we would have an
orderly, conditions-based way
to think about how to draw down
our forces there.
I can assure you, were I still
the Secretary of State,
with a commander-in-chief
like President Trump,
the Taliban
would have understood
that there were
real costs to pay.
-You were the first American
Secretary of State
to ever meet with the Taliban,
and you talked about how
they had agreed to join us
in the fight against terrorism.
Do you regret giving the Taliban
that legitimacy?
Do you regret
pressing the Afghan government
to release 5,000 prisoners,
which they did,
some of whom are now
back on the battlefield,
fighting with the Taliban?
-Chris, you make peace
with your enemies.
Chris, we never
trusted the Taliban.
You can ask them yourselves.
We didn't take the word
of the Taliban.
We watched their actions
on the ground.
When they did the right thing
and they helped us
against terror,
that was all good.
And when they didn't,
we crushed them.
-Alright, first of all, there's
literally a picture of you
meeting with a Taliban leader
the Trump administration
had released from prison.
That's from November --
nine months ago.
It's not some ancient photograph
from 30 years ago
that we had to unearth
by digging through
microfiche
at the National Archives
and then smuggling it out
in a rolled-up copy
of the Constitution
like Nick Cage
in "National Treasure,"
although I would give anything
to hear Nick Cage say
the word "microfiche."
[As Cage]
There's a secret message,
written by
Benjamin Franklin's ghost,
and it exists only
on microfiche!"
[ Normal voice ]
"National Treasure" --
three years after the beginning
of the war in Afghanistan.
Second, you think the Trump plan
would have been more orderly
than what's happening now?
You guys are the ones
who wanted to withdraw by May.
I have a hard time believing
Trump would have done it
in a more orderly way,
since nothing he ever did
was orderly.
He couldn't even withdraw from
an umbrella in orderly fashion.
Instead of armchair generals
engaging in
craven political-point-scoring,
what we need right now is
everyone calling
for the U.S. to accept
as many Afghan refugees
as possible.
That includes Afghans
who worked with the U.S. Army,
but it shouldn't be
limited to them.
We should welcome
anyone who wants to come.
-What should the Biden
administration be doing
for the people of Afghanistan
right now?
-Every Afghan who
is interested in doing so
should be given asylum
inside the United States.
There should be
an urgent process.
They should be fast-tracked,
and the logistics of it
can be, in part,
the responsibility
of one of the greatest
logistical organizations
on the planet, which is
the United States military,
and in particular,
the United States Air Force.
The idea that what the Biden
administration is doing
is helping get out Afghans
who worked for
the United States military
or served
the United States occupation.
That is a moral floor that is
functioning as a moral ceiling.
Working with the United States
should not be
a condition of acceptance
by American
refugee-admissions people.
-That's exactly right.
Taking in as many
Afghan refugees
as want to come here
and granting them asylum
is the bare minimum we can do.
We should be doing it
as fast as possible.
And we have the logistical
capability to do it.
I know it's not the same,
but when I got my vaccine
at a FEMA site,
I was in and out in 20 minutes
with a shot in my arm
and a CDC card
that for some reason
doesn't fit in my wallet.
And I know today probably
isn't the right time
to plug a product, but
I'm excited to announce
MyWallet, the new
awkwardly sized wallet,
built specifically to
hold your vaccine card.
MyWallet -- order now to receive
a free pair of MyWeirdPants,
the only pants with pockets
big enough to hold MyWallet.
Anyway, the point is,
we should be marshaling
the same logistical prowess to
take in as many Afghan refugees
as possible,
as quickly as possible.
The priority should be
getting them out now
and worrying about
the paperwork later.
And yet, for some reason,
the process for many Afghans,
including those who worked with
the U.S. has been a nightmare.
For example,
"The Atlantic" detailed
the flight of one "interpreter
who worked
alongside NATO combat units.
His first visa application,
like those of so many others,
was denied on spurious
bureaucratic grounds.
His second attempt
hung in limbo for years
as he tried to track down the
human-resources department
of the military contractor
that had employed him
and that subsequently
went through
several changes
of ownership and name."
Holy [Bleep],
just let him come here.
Screw the paperwork
and the red tape.
Why are we putting them through
a process
that's more complicated
than trying to switch
your Verizon bill
to a new address.
"No, I don't want to upgrade
to the Triple Play package.
I just want to move my service.
No, I do not want to add
a phone line.
I'm just moving.
I do not know
my account PIN number.
No, I do not know
my 11-digit billing code.
What's my dog's middle name?
Hey, what's your middle name?
He doesn't know."
And those attempting
to flee now,
in the face
of the Taliban onslaught,
are dealing with
the same chaos and confusion,
as NBC reported
over the weekend.
-We went to a processing center
today,
a private kind of pop-up office,
where there was two people
with a computer
in front of them.
And the office was packed
with Afghans coming in
who were trying to navigate
their way
through the U.S.
State Department's website.
All the documentation
that they need to provide
is in English.
They need to be
in multiple copies.
And a lot of the people
who were coming in
certainly didn't speak English.
'Cause it's
not just translators.
You have security guards
and you have contractors
and cleaners.
Not all of them speak English
and can navigate their way
through a website.
-Why are we making this
so [Bleep] complicated?
You need to navigate
a government website
with multiple copies
of your personal records
in a packed office with just
two people at a computer?
So, basic, it's the DMV.
We just re-created the DMV.
And no one should ever
have to go through that.
The last time I was at the DMV,
I waited in line so long,
I grew a mustache,
and they ended up putting
the wrong name on my license.
[ Laughter ]
And then my license
was too small
to fit in my new MyWallet.
[ Laughter ]
The tragedy that's unfolding now
is the culmination
of a two-decade-long legacy
of failure
left behind by politicians
of both parties
who repeatedly withheld the
truth from the American people.
When Bush first announced
the invasion of Afghanistan,
20 years ago,
the goal at the time,
according to Bush and
the politicians
that supported the war,
was to retaliate
against Al-Qaeda
and the Taliban regime
that was shielding it
and to prevent future attacks.
And as the war dragged on,
Bush continued to insist
the U.S. was succeeding
in its mission.
-I said a long time ago,
one of our objectives is
to smoke 'em out
and get them running
and bring them to justice.
We're smoking them out.
They're running.
And now we're going to
bring them to justice.
-Remember when the President
routinely used
the phrase "smoke 'em out"
like he was in an episode
of "Branded"?
And I'm sorry to drop
a "Branded" reference,
but sometimes you got to
pander to the people
who are too old
for the "MASH" jokes.
[ Laughter ]
Hope you guys liked it!
Hmm.
Throughout the war,
Bush promised
that the U.S. would not repeat
the history of failure
that had beset
past empires in Afghanistan.
-The history of military
conflict in Afghanistan,
it's been one of initial success
followed by
long years of floundering
and ultimate failure.
We're not gonna
repeat that mistake.
-The very thing they told us
wouldn't happen
is exactly what happened.
He sounds like
he's describing his own battle
with a poncho.
We had some initial success
followed by floundering
and ultimate failure.
But we won't be deterred.
Next, we're gonna try
an umbrella hat.
[ As Trump ] Umbrellas
aren't easy either.
Just FYI.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] They knew,
early in the war,
that the danger of
failure and instability
was very real,
and behind the scenes,
they even admitted they had
no idea what to do about it.
Secretary of Defense
Donald Rumsfeld
wrote in an internal memo,
only six months
after the war started,
"We are never going to get the
U.S. military out of Afghanistan
unless we take care to see
that there is something going on
that will provide the stability
that will be necessary
for us to leave."
"'Help!' he wrote."
He literally wrote
the word "help"
with an exclamation point.
You know, the same way
you text your spouse when you're
trapped in a conversation
at a dinner party that you
desperately want to get out of.
"Rick has been talking about
his metal cover band
for 20 minutes.
They're called
Age Against the Machine.
Help!"
The Bush administration
kicked off
a 20-year bipartisan tradition
of lying about the war
in Afghanistan and
shielding the American people
from the truth
of what was really happening.
We know that from
blockbuster reporting in 2019
from "The Washington Post,"
which got its hand
on a confidential trove
of documents
called "The Afghanistan Papers,"
in which senior U.S. officials
from both parties
admitted they'd been lying
about the reality
about how the war
was really going.
For example,
a three-star Army general
who served as the White House's
Afghan war czar
during the Bush and Obama
administration,
said in 2015, "We were devoid
of a fundamental understanding
of Afghanistan --
we didn't know
what we were doing.
What are we trying to do here?
We didn't have
the foggiest notion
of what we were undertaking."
The U.S.
foreign-policy apparatus
should not approach Afghanistan
the same way I approached
trying to install
a wireless router.
"Connect the router
to a broadband gateway
from your ISP
by inserting the Ethernet cable
to the port located
on the back of the TP-Link?
I don't have the foggiest notion
of what I'm undertaking!
Do you know how this works?
Why am I asking you?"
And instead of being honest
and telling that
to the American people,
officials cherry-picked and
misrepresented the data
to make the war look
like it was going
much better
than it actually was.
For example, an Army colonel
who served
as a senior
counter-insurgency adviser
to U.S. military commanders
in 2013 and '14
told government interviewers,
"Every data point was altered
to present
the best picture possible."
"Surveys, for instance,
were totally unreliable
but reinforced that everything
we were doing was right
and we became a self-licking
ice cream cone."
What? Is that a thing?
A self-licking ice cream cone?
That sounds like something
that would get pitched
on an episode of "Shark Tank"
where everyone laughs
but then Mark Cuban invests,
and three years later,
you hear that it somehow
sold for $1 billion to Apple,
and go to a party,
and all your friends
have self-licking
ice cream cones.
"Try it. It's called the iCone.
It's Siri-enabled.
It tracks your steps."
The majority of Americans
want the forever war
in Afghanistan to end.
Should have ended
a long time ago.
Ending it now
is the only option.
The one thing we can and must do
right now
is accept as many refugees
and grant as many Afghans asylum
as we possibly can,
as quickly as we can.
And if there's anyone left
in politics and the media
who disagrees, who fearmongers
about taking in
as many refugees as we can,
then when election time comes,
I hope voters will...
-Smoke 'em out.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.